[Music]
let us begin with a scenario you're
standing next to a six year old boy in
pomp row an isolated Aboriginal
community in Australia when you ask him
to point north key points precisely and
without hesitation your compass says
he's right you then ask the same
question to a group of your teachers not
all of them know the answer and the ones
who think they do end up pointing in
several different directions before
eventually reaching a state of confusion
why is it that a six year old boy in one
culture can do something effortlessly
that educated experienced adults in
another culture struggle to do the
surprising answer is layer aboard disky
reported in The Wall Street Journal in
2010 might be the substantial influence
of our native language over our thought
processes I will be using some of her
ideas to help me make my points the
relationship between language and
thought has provided a rich topic for
anthropological psychological and
linguistic research language like
culture is a system that we all create
and define together but on my culture
it's tightly structured the idea that
language might shape thought has often
been seen as crazy and irrational and
untestable at best however a new flurry
of cognitive scientific research has
caused a shift in consensus and led us
to wonder do the languages we speak have
an effect on the way in which we
construct our individual perceptions of
reality and how we see the world
consider a snippet from one of the most
well-known nursery rhymes in the
english-speaking world Humpty Dumpty sat
on a wall from this one liner roll alone
we can reveal so many of the differences
between languages if you were singing
Humpty Dumpty in English you would have
to mark the verb for tense and say sat
rather than sit to indicate timing but
an Indonesian you don't need to and in
fact you can't change the verb to mark
tense in Russian the verb that you would
use would reveal the gender of your
protagonist so your verb would be
slightly different if it was mr. Dumpty
than mrs. Dempsey during the sitting
lastly in Turkish you would have to
include in your verb how you obtained
the information that you were talking
about so you would use a slightly
different word if you saw Humpty Dumpty
sitting with your own eyes and if you
read or heard about it
so as you can see each language requires
very different things from its speakers
but does this mean that speakers of
English Turkish Russian and Indonesian
end up comprehending their experiences
differently just because they speak
different languages let's do another one
suppose that I want to tell you that I
saw Uncle Mike on 47th Street in Mayan
which is a language spoken in Papua New
Guinea the verb that I would use would
reveal whether the event happened just
now yesterday or a longer time ago
whereas an Indonesian it wouldn't even
reveal if it was still going on in
Russian the verb would reveal my gender
and in Mandarin Chinese I would have to
specify in my word choice for uncle
whether my uncle is maternal or paternal
and whether he's related to me by blood
or by marriage because there's different
types of words for all these types of
uncles but while the rules of all those
languages seem to add specific
information to the content of my
sentences some languages actually remove
information altogether in P Tana which
is a language spoken in the Amazon by a
tribe of the same name I couldn't say 47
because the PETA nah have no words for
numbers in fact in this way and many
others Peter not departs from what were
long thought to be essential features
for all languages as Rafaela vom beretta
reported in der Spiegel the pita and I
use only three pronouns they hardly use
any words associated with time or color
and pass verb conjugations don't exist
but what has perplexed linguist the most
is that the putana appeared to have no
words for numbers they don't use words
such as few or many there's one word hoy
which comes close to the numeral one
however how I can also be used to
describe relatively small quantities
such as two small fish as opposed to one
big fish Peter Gordon a psycholinguistic
Columbia University and Daniel Everett
from Bentley University visited the
Piton attempting to test their
mathematical abilities they were asked
to repeat patterns made between one and
ten or two remember whether Gordon had
placed five or eight objects in a can
the results were fascinating the Peter
now simply could not grasp the concept
of numbers as Everett stated as a
conclusion to his research of people
without terms for numbers does not
develop the ability to determine exact
numbers which compels us to deduce that
people are only capable of constructing
thoughts for which they possess actual
words and ultimately that language is
not just a way for
to express our thoughts it actually
plays a substantial role in creating
them it's not that the pita now we're
not intelligent enough to grasp
mathematical concepts this anomaly does
not lie on their mental capabilities
being lower than average it lies on the
origins and the purpose of their
language all languages have created and
molded by the culture of their speakers
and Pete and I is no different Everett
explains the cultural core of this
language with one simple formula live
here and live now the only thing of
importance that is worth communicating
to others is what is being experienced
in that very moment and that's why all
experience is anchored in the presence
this also explains why the patina
appeared to have no creation myth
explaining their existence when asked
about it they reply everything is the
same things always are
it's the employment of this carpet dim
culture the restricts abstract thought
and complicated connections to the past
limiting the language accordingly
now while we explore patina as an
example of how language can limit
cognition the cooks eye or language
spoken in the region of pamper Oh
actually serves as an example of
language improving it unlike English the
cooks I or language spoken in Pompeii
row does not employ relative spatial
terms such as left and right cooks I or
people actually talk in terms of
absolute cardinal directions that is
north south east and west in english we
also use those terms but only when
referring to large spatial scales but in
Kukai or they're used to all scales so
what this means is that in pombero one
might say the fork is southeast to the
knife or the boys standing west to julie
is my brother as a result people who
speak such languages that employ
absolute cardinal directions are
remarkably good at keeping track of
where they are because they need to do
this just to be able to speak properly
if their requirements if their language
that enforce and train this cognitive
prowess research has also shown that
language can influence how we perceive
and understand the concept of time
Ella's Gabi from the University of
California Berkeley gives speakers of
different languages a series of cards
showing temporal progressions such as a
man aging or a crocodile growing the
speakers were then asked to take the
shuffle photographs and arrange them in
correct temporal order English speaker
has given this task will arrange the
card so that time proceeds from left to
right but Hebrew speakers who write from
right to left will tend to arrange the
cards
proceeded from right to left which shows
us that writing direction in a language
can actually influence how we perceive
and understand the concept of time for
example in English the future is said to
be in front of us and the past is said
to be behind us and in a study carried
out by London miles it was proven that
speakers of English will tend to sway
their bodies forward when discussing the
future and backward when discussing the
past but in a Mara which is a language
spoken in the Andes the past is said to
be in front of us in the future behind
us and similarly as proven by Eve
Sweetzer figures of a Mara will tend to
sway their bodies forward when
discussing the past and backward when
discussed in the future but even more
incredible is that language can go
beyond affecting our own abilities in
our own conceptions to empower us to
mold how an event appears and influence
how others experience it lera bored
disks key outlines us with one simple
example consider former Vice President
Dick Cheney's quail hunting accident in
which Cheney accidentally shot Harry
Whittington in this case one could say
Cheney shot Whittington identifying
Cheney as the edge as the agent of the
event one could also say Whittington
were shot by Cheney still identifying
Cheney as the agent but distancing him
from the outcome lastly one could say
Whittington got shot leaving Cheney out
altogether Cheney himself said
ultimately I'm the guy who pulled the
trigger that fired the round that hit
Harry interposing a very long chain of
events between himself and the outcome
President George Bush said he turned
around and he heard a bird flush and he
pulled the trigger and he saw his friend
get wounded transforming Cheney from
agent Tamir witness and less than a
sentence these are all just a few of the
many fascinating findings of linguistic
differences in cognition the languages
we speak not only help us express our
thoughts but actually shape the very
thoughts we wish to express the patterns
that our languages are made of immensely
shaped how to construct our individual
perceptions of reality build our
opinions and interpret the incredibly
complex knowledge systems that we have
thank you
[Applause]